ثعلوب الطبيب
قَالُوا بَطُّوطَةْ عَيَّانَةْ *** تَحْتَاجُ و فَوْرًا لِطَبِيِبْ
وَأوِزَّةُ تَبْحَثُ حَيْرَانَةْ *** وَ دَجَاجَةٌ والدِّيِكُ قَرِيبْ
سَمِعَ الثَّعْلُوبُ المَكَّارْ *** خَلْفَ الحَائِطِ كُلَّ حِوَارْ
فَتَنَكَّرَ فِي زِىِّ طَبِيبْ *** كَيْ يَدْخُلَ مِنْ بَابِ الدَّارْ
طَبِيبْ طَبِيبْ أَنَا طَبِيبْ *** وأُعَالِجُ وأُدَاوِيِ المَرْضَى
مَنْ يَطْلُبُنِي سَوْفَ أُجِيبْ *** لَا أَتْرُكُ لِمَرِيضٍ عَرَضَا
ثعلوب الطبيب  طبيب ثعلوب الطبيب
يَا دِيكُ إني طبيب *** المرض أُشَخِصُ وأُدَاوِي
دَعْنِي أَدْخُلُ لِأُدَاوِيهَا *** أَنَا مُحْتَرِفٌ لَسْتُ بِهَاوِي
ثعلوب الطبيب  طبيب ثعلوب الطبيب
نَظَرَ الدِّيكُ إِلَيْهِ تَشَكَّكْ *** لِحَقِيقَةِ ثَعْلُوبٍ أَدْرَكْ
ذَيْلٌ مَنْفُوشٍ يَتَلَوَّى *** أَسْفَلَ مِعْطَفِهِ يَتَحَرَكْ
هَاهَاهَا هَاهَاهَا  كَذَّابٌ بَلْ أَنْتَ الثَّعْلَبْ *** مَكْشُوفٌ أَمْرُكَ يَا مَاكِرْ
بِالكَذِبِكَ لا لن تَتَغَلَبْ هَاهَاهَا هَاهَاهَا
كَذَّابٌ بَلْ أَنْتَ الثَّعْلَبْ *** مَكْشُوفٌ أَمْرُكَ يَا مَاكِرْ
بِالكَذِبِكَ لا لن تَتَغَلَبْ
جاء الكلب جاء الكلب *** بسرعة بسرعة هيا غادر
لم يبقى الا أن تخرج *** لَنْ تَدْخُلَ أَبَدًا يَا مَاكِرْ
ثعلوب الطبيب